ما كنا نخاف منه يبدو أنه على وشك الحدوث،
آن أوان أن يصل إلى كل دولة في العالم،
وجميع البشر ستتضرر،
(لكن مهلا عن أي شيء تتحدث؟)
وهل هناك حديث في العالم اليوم
غير حديث روسيا وأوكرانيا،
( نعم لكن ما هو الجديد اليوم
لتتحدث بنبرة خائفة هكذا؟)....
إنها الحرب يا سادة وليست أي حرب،،
إنها حرب تدمر ولا تبني وتقتل ولا تحيي،
إنها الحرب العالمية الثالثة، ماذا ؟!!!
نعم إنه ما سمعتم،،،
فروسيا جعلت أسحلة ردعها النووية
قيد الاستعداد، والغرب مستمر
بفرض العقوبات على موسكو،
فهل يتوقف الدب الروسي؟
لا لا يبدو ذلك ممكنا في الوقت الحالي،،،
والمشاهد خير دليل
بوتين يهدد وأمريكا والناتو تأخذها العزة بالإثم،
فإلى أين المصير يا قادة أقوى الدول في العالم
العالم خائف مترقب لما قد يحدث
جراء الأزمة الروسية الأوكرانية،
الأصابع على الزناد، والناس يضعون أيديهم
على قلوبهم فالحرب العالمية الثالثة
على الأبواب ولا ينقصها إلا
أن تضغط روسيا على زر الإطلاق'،،
هل هي النهاية؟ فلكل بداية نهاية،
والعالم قد بدأ ويبدو أنه سينتهي
لو قامت تلك الحرب الملعونة،!!!
لكن ولم على العالم أن يخاف من روسيا
في هذا الوقت بالذات؟
روسيا قررت تحريك صاروخها المسمى
بالشيطان المدمر،
تستعد  لإطلاق هذا الصاروخ إن واصل الغرب
ضغطهم عليها وليس هناك خيار آخر،
إذا فلتخافي يا أوروبا!!
وليخاف العالم من ورائكِ!!
الخبراء يقولون إذا كان لدى روسيا مثل هذا الصاروخ
فلدى أمريكا والغرب ما هو مساوٍ له
في القوة أو أقوى منه.
وهنا ستكون الكارثة التي لا تبقي ولا تذر.
لكن كيف حصل ذلك؟
جاء ذلك بعد أن التقى الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بقادته وقال لهم
(زملائي الأعزاء كما ترون أن الدول الغربية
لا تقوم بخطوات عدائية في المجال الاقتصادي فقط
،أقصد هنا العقوبات كما تعلمون،
ولكن الدول الأعضاء في الناتو تقوم بخطوات
عدائية ولذلك أوجه وزير الدفاع ورئيس الأركان
بوضع قوات الردع النووي في روسيا
في حالة تأهب خاصة، )
وبذلك فإن بوتين قد أمر قيادته العسكرية
بوضع القوة النووية في حالة تأهب قصوى،
وليس هناك مجال للشك في حرب طاحنة قادمة،
فهل من مستهدف غير أوكرانيا،
أم أن بوتين سيعلنها حربا نووية
على العالم بأسره أو بالأحرى من يقفون
في صف الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
(وكما يقول المصريون عليا وعلى أعدائي ي شيخ)
(مجنون كوريا يدخل على الخط)
المخاوف التي يثيرها المجنون كيم
رئيس كوريا الشمالية المسلحة نوويا
هي ذات المخاوف التي يخشاها الغرب
من روسيا، فبلاد كيم أجرت أكبر تجربة نووية
منذ العام ٢٠١٧،
اختبار باليستي متوسط المدى،
قادر على الوصول إلى جزيرة غوام الأمريكية،
وما يثير مخاوف الغرب وأمريكا
على وجه الخصوص، هو تصريح قائد القوات
الاستراتيجية لكوريا الشمالية سابقا،
عن بحثه لخطة تشمل اطلاقه ٤ صواريخ
من طراز هواسونغ١٢،
باتجاه الجزيرة الأمريكية،
بينما كان الرئيس السابق
للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية دونالد ترامب
قد حذر كيم أن أي تهديد للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
سيواجه بالنار والغضب،
هذه الصواريخ البالستية عابرة للقارات،
هذه التجارب تدخل العالم في دوامة
فهي بيد شخص مجنون،،
وبعد أن كان قد وقع على هدنة منع تصنيع السلاح
النووي، قال كيم أنه لم يعد ملزما بهذا الأمر،
بل وتعهد بتعزيز القدرات العسكرية لبلاده،
التقديرات تشير بأن يصل مدى هذه الصواريخ
إلى ٤٥٠٠كم، ..
صواريخ كيم تستفز اليابان وأمريكا خاصة
والعالم برمته فهل يجد كيم فرصة
في أزمة حليفه بوتين ويبدأ الحرب النووية؟..
(زيادة التوتر)
رئيس الشيشان قديروف، أرسل قوات للقتال
بجانب الروس، ويقول أن قرار بوتين صائب،
وسنتبع أوامره تحت أي ظرف من الظروف،،
مؤكدا أنهم لا يريدون الحرب،،
و الدفاع الروسية تقول أنه تم أسر ٤٧١ جنديا
أوكرانيا منذ بدء العمليات العسكرية..
ودخول دول جديدة على الخط الساخن للأزمة،
فإيرلندا تعلن تعليق الطيران الروسي
وهو ذات الموقف التي اتخذته العديد من الدول الأوروبية..
والجيش الأوكراني يدمر رتلا روسيا
بواسطة طائرة مسيرة من طراز
بيرقدار (التركية)، ما يجعل أردوغان
في مواجهة مصيرية أمام بوتين خلال الفترة القادمة....
لكن ما قد يريح العالم هو خبر واحد،
ربما يثلج صدور من وضعوا أيديهم على قلوبهم
فأوكرانيا أعلنت الموافقة على إجراء المحادثات
مع روسيا عند الحدود البيلاروسية.
لكن دون شروط مسبقة،
بعد وساطة بيلاروسية قد تكون هي الحل
الوحيد بين موسكو وكييف،
فهل تنجح هذه المفاوضات في إيقاف الحرب
العالمية؟ دعونا نرى!!!